That's weird.
I don't get people that think
climate change isn't real.
Had a hurricane here in the
Northeast to the magnitude
that it's never
supposed to happen.
But I really don't get people
that think the first thing I
mention has anything to
do with the [beep] second.
Like, that's the craziest
thing I've ever heard of.
It's not pollutants.
It's dudes kissing
dudes and God's mad.
What don't you get?
[laughter]
First off, if God is causing
these natural disasters
because gay-- like guys are
hooking up with guys and girls
are hooking up with
girls-- he's either
drunk or has terrible aim.
When has a hurricane
or a tornado ever
hit San Francisco ever?
Or West Hollywood?
Is he just drunk?
Like, stupid gays.
Oh, [beep] sorry, Nebraska.
My bad.
My bad again.
Wiped out cows and
crops yet again.
Missed all the gays.
And the thing is, look, if
we knew that gay activity,
specifically sexual
gay activity,
could cause natural
disasters, don't you
think we'd harness
that militarily?
[laughter]
We're America, OK?
We spend all our money on
[beep] guns to run the world.
If we could just
have dudes hook up
and cause tornadoes and
shit, that would be amazing.
Some Taliban commander
coming out of his fortress.
What's that in the distance?
Handsome men
shoulder to shoulder
as far as the eye can see.
They're not in fatigues.
They're dressed stylishly
and they're holding hands.
Is that ABBA I hear on the wind?
The music of ABBA and Erasure?
And then just a--
just a projected
amplified voice of a Sergeant.
It's like, left turn!
Dicks out!
[laughter]
And [beep].
And lightning bolts take out
the entire Taliban compound.
Tornadoes wiping out
America's enemies.
[applause]
What's that coming from the sky?
Lesbian paratroopers scissoring
as they float to the ground.
Monsoon rains wiping
out all of Al Qaeda.
We would give them their own
division of the military.
You kidding me?
The Army, Navy, Air
Force, Marines and gays.
Let them design
their own uniforms.
[beep] they'd look good, man.
Shit.